i have a favorite ass you guys
so i found out of this new position
apparently like none of us have ever
done but it's called amazon sex position
and i want to know if you guys can
demonstrate i'll do it with my brother
before i show you i'll deal with
jeremiah oh you guys
you want to do with me that hurt me
with you you want me to do it that
really hurt me you keep saying because i
keep seeing a brother a lot and looking
over yeah and i threw it out there like
like did you hear what i said let's do
it this is what i said what let's do it
let me hear it let me just i'll tell you
right
i'll do it with my brother like that
kind of right and you go no i'll do it
jeremiah this is you know what here he
is that goes you hurt me and and you
hurt him yeah how did i hurt you because
you said you'd rather do it with your
brother oh for comedy purposes and not
only that you didn't finish my
compliment what was the compliment
exactly
oh yeah yeah oh yeah
what's the world come down
holy guacamole
about it let's go to the amazon
look no
how about this i will give you no steve
you and i will do that position and i
will do the compliment wow while i'm in
the position okay all right okay all
right
i'm going to be on the bottom oh i see
what's going on i got to be on the
bottom all right i got to be on the
bottom okay you got to be on top but his
legs have to be up
all right so our client and i next her
i feel like we're the right proportion
yeah
steve put your knees under his knees
and bobby
now put your knees in the ground put
your knees up put your knees on the
ground
put your knees on the ground
put your knees on the ground
knees on the steve put your knees on the
ground now go back and forth now go back
and forth
go back and forth
[Applause]
put your knees on the ground
i want to say
don't laugh don't worry i'm so proud
i'm so proud of you you're killing the
game in the podcast world and you're
like you're fighting your own
voice do you so excited about your life
okay yeah okay okay get off now okay all
right oh dude oh my god
steve was that comfortable or painful oh
well i'm sorry because me and jeremiah
did a mechanical bull riding challenge
can you talk a little bit about it bobby
says he's the best at that he said he's
number one dude have you done it
jeremiah tell tell him what we did so
we're i didn't you know there's a
downtown sandy i haven't been there
we used to hang out just in escondido
yeah but he had a show in uh downtown
san diego but then there's bars and
stuff yes he finds like a right next to
the right next to the comedy club yeah
yeah yeah they're good comedy coming to
company right by right yeah